some of the most controversial members
of the Republican Party are about to see
greater influence in Congress house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy and his allies
started assigning lawmakers to
influential committees and the list
includes some who had previously been
stripped of committee assignments Nancy
Cortez is following this Nancy good
morning
good morning Nate and believe me they
pay attention to those committee
assignments here at the white house
because these are the members who are
going to be conducting investigations
who are going to be grilling
Administration officials and even in
some cases moving to impeach those
officials most notably you've got two
Republicans now being assigned to
committees after they were stripped of
their committee assignments not that
long ago Trump Allied Georgia
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green she
is going to be sitting on the powerful
Homeland Security committee which has
jurisdiction over the Border she'd be
part of any move to impeach secretary
Alejandro mallorcas which some in the
GOP have been pushing for now you'll
require call that Taylor green was
kicked off of her assignments nearly two
years ago for racist and anti-semitic
social media posts she has also
continually questioned the 2020 election
results and she has pushed a variety of
conspiracy theories some of them having
to do with Nash National Security
Arizona representative Paul gosar he's
going to return to his seat on the
national resources committee after he
was removed for a social media post that
depicted violence against promised
prominent house Democrats both of these
members have also reportedly been
assigned to the house oversight
committee which would likely take the
lead in investigations of the White
House and Hunter Biden that's very
significant now as for the embattled New
York freshman Congressman George Santos
well he's going to sit on the small
business committee as well as the
science SpaceX technology committee
despite lying extensively about his
business record and despite the fact
that he is currently facing multiple
ethics complaints and continued
questions about his campaign finances
Tony
yep we'll be following that one Nancy
thank you very much